how can you easily have certificates for
all your users or services in different
environments while also maintaining zero
trust and the ability to integrate with
other gcp services i'm glad you asked
certificate authority service cas has an
answer
let's learn a bit more about it
when your organization is running on
multiple environments and you need them
to be able to talk to each other while
maintaining zero trust it can be hard to
find a solution for certificates that
isn't laborious and inefficient
you can have your identity provider
trust multiple different certificate
authorities and then make sure there's
access to the same certificates at
runtime which increases risk and pushes
responsibility for doing federation to
the service
you can create a middleware solution
with admin access on both sides but then
you have to deal with the challenges of
authoring deploying maintaining scaling
and everything else that comes with
building a service
or you have to create a whole new
identity provider and recreate all the
accounts in it which if you have 10 000
accounts takes a long time and isn't
very efficient
and none of these options would allow
you to easily have integration with
other google cloud services that you may
already use today
thankfully cas can help
you can use cas with workload identity
federation and obtain a certificate to
attest to third-party identities on-prem
or in other clouds
workload identity federation leverages
workload identity pools to give
third-party identities access to google
cloud services
you can grant on-premise or multi-cloud
workloads access to google cloud
resources without using a service
account key
using cas allows you to use your current
identity provider and existing
credentials for a certificate for all
your users or services across the globe
meaning you can talk to workloads
on-prem or in other clouds and get
point-to-point connectivity to google
cloud services across a single network
with zero trust principles
you also avoid manually configuring
access policies using ip addresses and
you can issue certificates at scale with
the principle of least privilege saving
significant time and resources while
increasing security
plus if you're on prem it makes it
easier to move stuff to the cloud in the
future if needed because your identity
information is all set up and doesn't
change
let's imagine you're an organization
with 10 000 users and you have microsoft
active directory as your identity
provider
each person has an account integrated
with their email their calendar their
passwords etc and you want each user to
get a certificate so that your workloads
on prem can talk securely to workloads
in gcp
you can now issue a certificate from ca
service reflecting their federated
identity
you don't have to go and recreate all
these identities in another provider or
one of the other cumbersome options we
discussed earlier
and the setup is pretty simple first
create a workload id pool with your id
provider and teach ca service which part
of the id token should be reflected in
the certificate
then configure cas workload with the
workload certificate requester iam role
next configure workloads to perform
token exchange with sds before
requesting certificates from cis
then request a certificate from cas
using the reflected spiffy subject mode
and finally let it run and every
workload that wants a certificate will
be given a credential that was
previously set up and this is then
allowed to be exchanged for a
certificate
what's really nice is that all of these
steps can be fully automated so as soon
as you bring a workload to life it can
get a certificate and talk to the right
environment securely
if you'd like to know more about cas how
it increases security and efficiency and
decreases risk with third party
environments or want to see detailed
instructions on how to set it up please
check out the links in the description
below
until next time thanks for watching
you